well a lot of you have been contacting
us about and complaining about long
lines to get the vaccine and then
we will get tips on where there are no
lines now we are happy to report some
good news today
sally jaramillo is live outside the las
vegas convention center a location
with reported long lines but not today
right sally
christian that's right that may be the
reason why vaccine hours have been
extended as you can see right behind me
there's a lot of vehicles but there are
no lines and people tell me everything
moved along well today
earlier today i visited other
vaccination sites such as the heritage
park senior facility in henderson
the site is offering 500 vaccinations
per day by appointment only
although a lot of people showed up to
get the vaccine no one waited in line
sebastian keska took his mom to get her
second dose
at the las vegas convention center he
was glad there was no way
i'm very ecstatic you know i don't have
to worry about her contracting the virus
there's still a small chance that she
can get it but it's not as
aggressive not as not not as scary
as for the hours of operation being
extended for the las vegas convention
and catchment center people tell me they
hope
this encourages others to get vaccinated
now for a full list of those hours and
other locations where you can get
vaccinated
make sure to visit our website
8newsnow.com reporting live
sally caramillo 8 news now